I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense logically in sports we go okay
if I want to play basketball I'm gonna
get coaching from yeah asking Hill but
in life we get coaching typically from
people that are terrible at
relationships and terrible with their
finances so we really start on a basic
level with people and say look you gotta
be willing to a lot of let us help you
in these areas because any business we
help you develop you're gonna ruin it if
you don't handle your life properly you
know and that's really been the game
changer and we start really from the
beginning where we ask somebody a simple
question which my mentors asked me a
long time ago where they said look they
said what's the question that you get
asked your whole life which is how do
you what you want to be when you get
older what do you want to be and we said
doctor fireman lawyer whatever and you
know it's the wrong question the right
question is is how do you want to live
what do you want you let forget about
career forget about job forget about
anything that if you could I don't know
have 100 million a half a million
whatever the number is how would your
life look what would you do on a daily
basis how would you give to charity how
much time would you spend with family
what kind of schools would you send your
kids to you know what would you and your
wife do instead of having you know
trying to squeeze life into nights and
weekends when you're dead tired what
would your life look like with your
spouse you know like all these questions
and then you know anytime we ask
somebody that their brain you start to
see like things firing in the brain
they're gone oh my gosh my whole life
would be different you know and you go
okay well if that's the case you need to
figure out a vehicle that could then
produce the life that you want
so my asking the right question yep I
mean you know you say that and we've
talked about school before and kind of
the institution and the structure and
the curriculum even but you know it's
like almost like we're ingrained into
this process where it's like 9:00 to
5:00 all week we do things we don't want
to do and that's just normal it's like
what if you just like stopped all of
that [ __ ] and just said what do I really
want to do right how do I really want to
live my life would I take trips would I
be an artist would I you know would I go
what I learned some people while
I'm the older I get the more I want to
learn some thought some of it has to do
with learning so that's an incredible
first steps is saying you know how do
you want your life to look and there's
so many people that just buy into this
rat race this like her to say like the
human race it's like a race to no finish
line to death a race to death that sucks
you know I mean that's just not that
much fun to just you know you know go to
work to live and you sound like you live
to work then yeah alright so what
happens after they start going oh I
would do this I would do that I would do
that I'm afraid if I actually answered
that question I would probably just stop
working and I just live and have a
garden and a hundred dogs and camp of
course yes we love camping yeah anyway
we've customized your life it's not
about just making enough money so then
you could sit at home and just do
nothing or or whatever it's about like
what is your life gonna mean yeah like
when you know when you pass away yeah
like are people gonna remember you
because you left them mark like where
people's lives better off because you
truly lived yeah really
oh my gosh legacy is so much what we
talked about yeah because look I got
scared at like 17 years old when I went
down to Florida for my grandparents like
the retirement home community thing and
I and I literally I remember this as
clear as day being around 78 years old
and going this is what everyone worked
so hard for to play shuffleboard in the
afternoon
- and then shuffle - there yeah like
their house home just sit in the kitchen
and yeah I think she'd get it so I was
like why are we working our entire lives
to then retire quote-unquote to some
community and I'm look I'm not I don't
mean to make it sound like I'm putting
it down or anything like that there's so
many people out the generalities right
these are just generalities these aren't
specifics yeah
macro not micro exactly but it's like I
guess the question is is like are you
fulfilled with the life that you're
living and if you're not well then are
you do you have the guts to go out and
make some changes that's it
I mean that's like even when I look at
myself and retiring at 36 and it's like
do you have the guts to just say I don't
want to do that anymore even though
that's all you know that's you know
where you it's your reputation it's your
identity it's safe it's familiar it's
like do you have the guts to go do it
anymore
I'm not happy
[Music]